-Thank you so much for tuning in
and watching "The Tonight Show."
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
I really appreciate this.
It makes me happy.
I'm happy to be here.
Let's get to the news
and some jokes here.
Well, guys, I hope everyone had
a nice Labor Day weekend.
It was actually a busy
Labor Day for President Trump.
He held a 45-minute press
conference where he launched
an attack against leaders
of the U.S. military.
He launched more
insults at Joe Biden.
And he even launched something
from his nose.
[ Slow-mo rumbling noise ]
Pshew!
[ Audience ohs ]
Ooh-ee! Oh! What was that?
Eww!
People are wondering, man.
Was that a booger?
Was it drugs?
I'd like to think he was
eating crackers
by sticking them up his nose.
Hey, you know what could have
stopped that projectile?
A mask.
[ Laughter ]
Even worse, whatever
flew out of his nose
hit that U.S. Open
line judge in the throat.
And that's --
[ Laughter ]
You don't like to see that.
Well, everyone is still talking
about "The Atlantic's" report
that Trump called fallen service
members "losers" and "suckers."
And yesterday, when Trump
was asked about it,
he once again denied
ever saying it.
Listen to his response.
-Who would say a thing
like that?
Only an animal would say
a thing like that.
-Yeah. I bet if an animal
did say that,
it would probably be this one.
I don't want to -- I don't --
Look --
[ Laughter ]
Other than the 245 times Trump
has actually called someone
a loser and a sucker
on Twitter,
he'd never say
anything like that.
That's right. Trump allegedly
made outrageously
offensive remarks,
so you know what that means.
Nothing happens to Trump,
and Billy Bush gets fired.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm not sure what's
more upsetting,
the comments Trump
reportedly made,
or what he's going to do
to change the subject.
[ As Trump ] "And that's why
we're nuking the moon."
[ Laughter ]
That was a pretty crazy
press conference.
At one point, Trump went off
on a rant
attacking military leaders.
Because when you're in a scandal
about calling soldiers names,
the best defense is to
antagonize their bosses.
Trump was like, "And this goes
all the way to the top, people,
whoever is the chief
of all the commanders."
[ Light laughter ]
If that wasn't enough,
at that same press conference,
Trump told a reporter
to take off his mask.
Watch this.
-The issue of what happened
when you were in France
continues to be a story.
-You're going to have to
take that off, please.
Just -- you can take it off.
You're --
How many feet are you away?
-I'll speak a lot louder.
-Well, if you don't take it
off, you're very muffled.
So if you would take it off,
it would be a lot easier.
-I'll just speak a lot louder.
Is that better?
-[ Huffs ]
It's better, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What is Trump doing?
He's the president
of the United States,
not Velma at the end of
an episode of "Scooby Doo."
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasps ]
Meanwhile, it looks like all the
scandals that have plagued
Trump's presidency are starting
to catch up with him.
Check it out.
-The president is disputing
a report in "The New York Times"
that his campaign has squandered
its fund-raising advantage.
-They burned through
$800 million of the $1.1 billion
they raised since 2019,
some of what are described
as vanity splurges.
-Yeah. You could tell
he's strapped for cash
because now all his speeches
have product placements.
"We'll repeal Obamacare
and replace it with...
delicious, nutritious
Boar's Head --
[ Laughter ]
Boar's Head cold cuts."
I don't know what
I'm holding there.
Like a jar of cold cuts?
-A ham.
-A ham. That was good.
Give up the ham.
Trump's campaign has already
spent $800 million,
and he's still losing
by almost ten points.
So far,
it's the worst money spent
since you bought
Skechers Shape Ups.
[ Laughter ]
I'm working out.
I'm going to the bar.
I'm feeling good, man.
I gained a few,
but maybe it's muscle.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, they blew through
$800 million in a few months.
Who's running his campaign?
Trump in the '80s?
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah.
-In the '90s?
Now Trump's claiming
he's going to spend
up to $100 million
of his own money.
It's a great idea.
Mike Bloomberg heard
and was like,
"Yeah, good luck with that."
[ Laughter ]
But the Trump campaign isn't
worried, especially because
they're about to bring in
a few million
from Don Jr.'s
Visine endorsement.
[ Laughter ]
The campaign also just spent
$156,000 on planes
that pull banners.
So their advertising strategy
is basically the same
as the Clam Shack down
at the Jersey Shore.
You can tell Trump's campaign is
running out of money
because this weekend
they sunk a bunch of boats
for the insurance money.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my goodness.
But this morning,
Trump denied the report
and sent a tweet saying that
they have lots of money.
It would have been more
convincing if Trump's next tweet
wasn't his Venmo handle
and the prayer hands emoji.
Could we see the last line
of his tweet again?
Trump's tweets look like a spam
e-mail you shouldn't open.
It's like, lots of dollar signs
and energy.
Oh, that sounds --
Meanwhile, just when it seemed
like things couldn't sink
any lower for Trump
and his supporters,
it appears that they
literally can.
Watch this.
-There were several boats
that sank during a lake parade
supporting President Trump.
The sheriff's office says calls
started coming in almost
immediately after the parade
started on Saturday.
At least three of the boats were
recovered,
but some are still
underwater.
-You know if Trump
were on board,
he would have been like, "Out of
the way, women and children.
Presidents first.
Okay?
Thank you. Do you mind
if I step on your back
just to get out of here?
Thank you."
The event's Facebook page said,
"Let's really make a statement."
Unfortunately, that statement
was, "Help, my boat is sinking."
[ Laughter ]
Ironically, while the boats
were sinking,
Republicans in Congress
spent two months debating
whether or not to send them
a life raft.
-Ah!
-Uh, that's your "New York
Times" joke of the week...
[ Laughter ]
...sponsored by
Boar's Head cold cuts,
the finest jarred cold cuts.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, man, this isn't good.
This weekend in California,
a wildfire started burning,
and it was caused by
a pretty unlikely source.
This is real.
Listen to this.
-The El Dorado fire here
in San Bernardino started by
a smoke-generating
pyrotechnic device
used at a gender reveal party.
-Oh, my goodness.
They used pyrotechnics?
Seriously.
It's a gender reveal,
not a KISS concert.
[ Laughter ]
Are you serious?
Oh, man.
Even people who fall off cliffs
taking selfies are like,
"What a bunch of idiots."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it turns out the couple is
expecting six months in jail
and thousands of legal fees.
And finally, listen to this.
The founder of Jelly Belly
announced that he is
going to give away
a Florida candy factory
as part of a nationwide
treasure hunt.
It's great until you find out
it's the factory that makes
all the buttered popcorn
flavored jelly beans.
We have a great show for you
tonight.
The very funny Joel McHale
is here.
[ Applause ]
His latest album "Detroit 2"
is number one on iTunes.
We'll be talking to him,
and then he'll be performing
his latest single,
"Harder Than My Demons."
Big Sean is here.
[ Applause ]
Love Big Sean.
We're back after two weeks.
Did you guys have a good break?
-Um...yeah.
-Yeah.
-Wow. You didn't enjoy yourself?
-It was okay.
-Yeah.
What, just a lot of...
things happening?
-Yeah, you know.
Just chillin'.
-Hmm.
-Hangin' out around the crib.
You know?
-What are you --
Are you watching
anything on TV?
What are you watching now
that's good?
-Oh, man, what am I watching?
You know, I've been watching
this thing
called "Love Swindler."
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what? What?
-We -- we have different --
-It's crazy.
It's like --
-Is it American?
-Yeah, it's on Showtime.
It's about this dude who like --
he swindled all these
unsuspecting
middle-aged white women
out of their life savings.
He just kept like
reinventing himself.
He was like a plastic surgeon,
and then a real estate agent.
Then he had, like,
this crab restaurant,
and he just -- you know,
he would go
from town to town, like,
reinventing himself.
-Wait. "Love Swindler"?
-Yeah.
-And it's a documentary?
-It's a documentary series,
yeah.
-Oh, I want to check
that out.
That's what I'm all about.
-It's on Showtime.
Yeah, you know, I'm about
the swindle life too.
-No, no, no, no, no.
No, I'm into documentaries.
I'm into documentaries.
-Yes.
-That's what I meant.
-Me too, yeah.
-I'm watching --
I'm watching "The Vow."
Are you watching that?
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-Whew!
Dude, it's on HBO Max.
-Yeah.
-I have like ten HBOs now.
-I know, right?
-I had to sign up
for a whole new thing.
-It's crazy.
-HBO Max. A whole new jam.
-You can never find --
like, you know,
if you don't watch something
in its entirety,
you can never get back
to the platform
that you were
watching it on.
It's like,
"Wait, where did this thing --"
-Yeah, where did I find that?
-Yeah.
-Well, this, I found --
I read about it,
and then I found it,
and then I signed up,
and now I'm on that.
But this thing
isn't a whole jam.
You only get two -- it's only up
to like two or three --
-Yeah, yeah. It's, you know,
a little bit at a time.
I've been watching that too,
"The Vow."
-It's fantastic.
You see it, Quest?
-I have not seen it, no.
-Dude, it is nuts.
Real deal, real deal
craziness.
It's wild.
I watched that.
I watched "Class Action Park"
on HBO Max --
I feel like --
Boar's Head cold --
The NBC --
But, no,
"Class Action Park,"
have you seen that?
-No.
-Have you seen that,
you guys?
It's a real thing.
Anyone here seen that?
It's -- Gerard, yeah.
Yeah, we went to it.
In my high school, I went to --
Action Park was a theme park
in New Jersey.
But it basically has no rules.
It's like -- and people were
just getting hurt
every single --
There was, like,
an alpine slide
where you would just --
it was a plastic thing
you sat on, and it had
a control stick
that would, like, have
"brake" or "fast,"
and it was always broken,
so it doesn't matter.
You just zoom by,
and if you tried to stop,
you'd scrape up your elbows
and, like -- oh, it's crazy.
And they had --
-In New York?
-And that's the fun of the game?
Like, that's --
-No, it's not supposed to be.
It's supposed to be --
it's supposed to be fun.
The theme park,
there's no rules.
That was my first time
and last time I bungee jumped.
And -- and you --
cliff diving.
You would jump off this cliff.
And you'd jump off like an
18-foot cliff into a pool,
a swimming pool.
And then, people would just
jump on you
because there's no rules.
-That's crazy.
-No, it's really crazy.
So it was called Action Park.
I loved it.
I think I did.
I don't even remember.
It was probably terrible. But --
-It sounds pretty terrible.
It sounds like Action Park
was about that swindle life.
[ Laughter ]
-It might be on an
episode, man.
Never know.
I got to check it out.
But we're here.
We're back in the building.
I'm psyched to see
everybody here
and everyone for doing this.
And very, very cool.
Upstairs, "Late Night
With Seth Meyers"
is back in the studio
at 30 Rock.
Welcome, guys. Welcome back!
[ Applause ]
That's awesome, man.
You can feel --
You can feel the vibe,
I think, there, I think,
in the city walking around
in New York City.
I think, you know, people are
out with masks and doing it,
but it's happening,
and I'm psyched
Seth and the gang are back.
Seth, what do you have planned
for us this week?
-Seth: Hey, Jimmy,
it's so great to be back
in the building
with you again.
Tonight, we have Jane Fonda
and our mutual friend from
"SNL," Jorma Taccone.
And later in the week,
John Cleese and Sheryl Crow,
and then Thursday,
Michael Cohen is going to
tell us about his new book.
And all-new "Closer Looks"
all week.
Hey, and I'm sorry I can't come
down and visit, but your kids,
cute as they may be, they look
like super spreaders to me.
Also, I am going to send down
some sushi
that I saved for you
from before we left the building
in March because
I know you love sushi.
It was salmon, but now
it looks like eel.
Anyway, enjoy, bud.
-Well, we'll be watching.